hi guys and welcome to episode 111 this
is officially the first let's play video
with three consecutive numbers in its
count number which is I don't know
actually reach the second time but I
suppose it's pretty cool last time I
asked like about the transfer track and
I will do that some other time by the
way I am really glad about all the
feedback and this is really something
that I want to get out there thats
feedback is something which i don't mind
just if you think my thing sucks just
tell me my thing sucks and tell me why
my thing sucks and what you would
suggest i would do because to be very
honest there a couple of points not only
am I pretty an experienced do I not have
too much knowledge about theme parks in
general so that there are a couple of
areas where I can definitely still
improve and don't know really too much
about them I also have to say that the
reason why I started sharing my things
in general is just to get better and
it's to be very honest also what I
really like about the roller coaster can
three community the fact that everybody
watches in response to each other stuffs
at each other stuff and helps each other
out and that's also what I do still like
about presenting my own project so if
you ever have any feedback criticism to
give me then go ahead if you think there
is something really terribly wrong with
my stuff and you have a good explanation
why then I'm always open for that so
thank you about all that by the way but
I am going to have to do that some other
time because i already had this episode
pre-recorded i was actually thinking
that i might turn this into two episodes
but i don't really have anything else so
this is just gonna be a longer episode
for once so enjoy that I suppose the
only thing that will really be going on
in this episode is this Q line and some
foliage have something which I have to
say about this Q line is that it's
something that I've really
procrastinated and Q lines in general
are really something that I don't know
too much about it's kind of similar to
the transfer track in that respect since
well the transfer track I didn't really
know anything about really how I would
do it and I will get a extra building or
at least an extra part of the track in
so that I can store the cars on a
different part of the track so i will
the end i will do that in the future
the Q is something which i also don't
know too much about I did a tiny bit of
internet research sort of and found out
that there are actually some cues which
do have a fence in the middle I don't
know if this is completely how it works
but I found a couple of examples for it
so I figured it would be realistic to
have a fence in the middle which would
still have openings here and there but
using that I could have a one tile white
q but also you know actually make it
realistic because I felt like a one tile
white q is just too wide or leave chaos
in lines realistically but I didn't want
a half Thai or white cube because in
Game hopeless I why this is really too
narrow you can barely fit any people in
that so the option that I opted for was
to get a 1 tile wide Q in with a fence
in the middle but also with openings in
between it and a couple of little bins
actually because I yeah I did find that
a couple of rides and realized at that I
don't know exactly how realistic it is
or if there are any better ways to do
this or if there's anything really wrong
with my queue line but this is basically
the way that I am doing it at the moment
I do feel pretty confident about the
foliage I do have to say that I am kind
of breaking in on a rule that I would
not like to break too much which is the
fact that there's gonna be many flowers
around this queue but still I do like
the foliage overall but really I can
never stress this enough tones start to
spam your flowers too much because
people are gonna have to maintain all
that stuff and it is really hard to turn
your entire park into a flower vests and
just have your maintenance people
actually care for all the flowers at the
same time but I did want to make this
look at tiny bit nicer I'll cold i set a
tiny bit okay another case i did want to
make this look a bit nicer because i
didn't want this to turn into a big old
forest which is something which happens
to me all the time and i feel like it is
a very common pitfall and i would like
to say that you don't always have to
fill every single empty grassy area in
your Park with foliage how I would
recommend
you don't actually because it is always
great to just leave some areas open you
can even have some grocery planes here
and there just make sure that you have
some open areas with either low shrubs
some grass or other things and not just
have your entire park be a one big
forest even the efteling which is known
for being one big forest has its empty
spaces and it's more sunny places well
that sounded a tiny bit poetic and oh my
god okay and in any case that is pretty
much why I also decided to make this
area a tiny bit oh my god I'm not even
doing that on purpose that's why I
decided to make this area a bit more
open I really have to move away from
saying that but I also have to move away
from talking about it so yeah that's why
I decided to just get a bit of flowers
in here it was really hard to find
anything else that I could fill this
area with without making it too wide and
without turning it into a forest so
that's why I decided to go for a very
small flowers some grass here and there
and some simple shrubs and that's
basically how I wanted to do the foliage
over here the rest is just going to be
the very standard tree line method and
that I've always pretty much used and
that's always pretty much happening on
the topic of foliage by the way I feel
like at least this is how I see it you
have to really find a balance between
very dense foliage and very light
foliage and not having as much many huge
trees and getting some small flowers and
grass in instead because there are
basically two sides that you can go
towards when you go for very dense
foliage it either may look very cramped
and end up very small and claustrophobic
or it can really help towards making
your park look very cozy and traditional
and I always find it hard to actually
get that cozy look with very dense
foliage that is really all around your
parts in a very compact way while
preventing it from looking very
obstructive and very tight together and
like it's it's very claustrophobic and
that's why i figured i would get it a
little bit more open over here and try
to get a more
a warm inviting look without having very
dense foliage I the thing about this is
that i don't really have any way or
figuring out whether i want very dense
foliage Foley's that's very close to my
parts and that you really can't see
through or whether I want to make it a
bit more open to prevent it from being
very claustrophobic but it is just I
feel like it really has to do with the
width of your paths as well give it if
you have very wide parts very large open
spaces in general I always tend to go
for foliage that's really close to my
parts really close to my scenery to make
sure that my open spaces don't become
too large and you don't get that really
large open space feeling which I would
like to avoid while at the same time if
I very narrow paths I always tend to
have my foliage a bit further away from
that part that's at least how I usually
do it and that's my entire view and that
I don't know for sure if that's really
how you should do it but that's
basically the rule that I like to follow
when I decide whether I want to make my
foliage very dense and close to my path
or very light and further away from my
part and since this is obviously a very
small Q and the paths that are around
the coaster are also quite small I
wanted to make this a bit more open
another thing is that i find generally
especially in bali coasters it just
looks more fun if you have a more open
area because you can put small scenery
items in it you can fit interesting
flowers in it and it's just more fun to
make but also look at so that's why i
wanted to do that here's also the thing
about these litter bins i have no idea
that's actually a realistic thing I've
never even seen that before on any
roller coaster and I've never done it
before it just so happened to be that
when I was looking up things and I
actually found some courses that had
little bins in the cuse I figured here
are not sickly a pretty good point I
don't even know how I've never even had
that I mean it seems pretty logical that
you would have little bins to prevent
your cues from being well litter bins
themselves but I don't even know that's
too much of a realistic thing and
honestly here is something which the
only thing which I feel kind of guilty
about is the fact that I don't have a
lot of theme park knowledge and I don't
know if every
but he knows this at this point but I've
barely gone to anything books in my life
I haven't been to one in a couple of
years right now and this is really where
I feel bad about the fact that I don't
have too much theme park knowledge
because even though I'm very much
interested in this game I really like
making buildings designing landscapes I
don't really know too much about theme
parks and that's really my big issue so
that's why I might actually have to get
some more feedback on that in the future
and really improve and look look up more
things about that definitely that's at
least for me a very large room for
improvement because I just don't know
too much about the in pikes that's one
big issue which is why I am really
insecure and which is why I am probably
also making a lot of trouble with my
transfer tracks and queues and very
theme park specific things like that so
yeah that's a bit of an explanation of
why i am not too good at boloco shoes
while i may be good at doing other
things and why i look to other people
for help about that you'll notice that
there's a bit of me just scrolling over
the park and looking at things and
suddenly building a bit of random
foliage which is simply because i didn't
really know of things that i would do
and this is also one of the reasons why
usually most of my videos at 10 minutes
long and why usually stream for about
two hours it's I can get a very clear
goal of what i want to do exactly and
after that I feel like it becomes a bit
too random I don't want my time lapses
to just be me looking around and looking
at small things that I can do here and
there it's obviously something that I
need to do every now and then just
improve things but it's something that I
would not like to do on a episode Lee
basis if that's a word so there that's a
bit annoying next thing that I did do
was the ferris wheel but that's honestly
not too much interesting stuff there's
that's obviously inspired by the london
ferris wheel the lawn and I of course
but there's also different 1i think in
England maybe even some other ones in
any case there are some white ferris
wheels in England they appear to be
quite a trend and that's why i figured i
would get a very on here obviously it is
not quite as large as I feel like a
really large ferris wheel over here with
lately break the function of the clock
tower at the moment of being the major
weenie of this area so if you have a
winning in your area make sure that it's
actually the largest thing in your area
and don't build anything larger than
that which is why I wanted to stay away
from a very large ferris wheel another
reason is because I still think I need a
weenie at the end of my main street and
I don't have anything at the moment and
I do think that the large ferris wheel
at the end of the main street of Verona
Valley worked really well to make the
main street look a lot better so I think
at least that's the current idea that I
might get aim ferris wheel at the end of
the main streets in this park at least
that's the only thing that I can really
come up with at this point in time I've
considered drop towers and perhaps a
observation tower stuff like that maybe
some sort of monument but I wanted to be
something that is not any nation
specific so i can get a eiffel tower in
that's all fun and stuff but you know
it's a very friends thing and I don't
have that since this is supposed to be a
bike that's about Eurasia in general a
you can't you can't really show the
essence of Eurasia in one building so I
would rather not even try to do that
there's also the thing there's a couple
of ideas i also have one other ideas to
have a castle which is also a bit of a
problem because you can't make a castle
that has everything of eurasia in it and
i have considered actually trying thats
to do a castle which has elements from
every single Eurasian sort of culture in
general in it but that just feels
impossible i don't think i could even do
that well and actually make it work so
at the moments i think i will have a
ferris wheel over there eventually but
i'm not too sure yet only thing why i'm
really talking about that is because
this right here this little bows wheel
it's not workin out too well and this is
actually what i would like to say with
my entire story about half wide I mean
hostile wide queues in roller coaster
can three because this queue is half a
tire white and I really feel as if half
a tire was just way too narrow it's
doable for cues that just zigzag in one
small building or something like that
but for cues that
go through an environment with trees and
scenery around it I think how the tile
is wide enough then again the dilemma is
that I feel like a full tile is too wide
but then again it's well acoustic in
three and three-quarter tiles there is
something that you can barely even work
with they exist but it's just it's
really a big problem ants not fun at all
so I think this is how i'll keep the
ferris wheel right now but once again
i'm very very uncertain about the way
that this phase we always working out so
far so i might change that end up you
two I don't know I just wanted to get a
ferris wheel over here and it looks good
now I just need to make sure that the
things around the photos will look good
as well and that's a bit of my weak
point when it comes to theme park
realism I'm really not too good in any
case i'll try to fix that and figure out
what I should do with that's also what
I'll try to do is next episode I should
remember to actually do an overview of
the park hopefully I won't forget it but
at the end of the episode I should be
doing a small overview of what I
currently have because it's been
requested and that's gonna be it so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next episode bye